i i've always had the metabolism of a
racehorse and while i have it i'm using
it and i just i'm constantly eating
thinking about food talking about food
and i got into cooking because i would
say to my mom like oh can you make that
like guac burger i saw guy fieri make on
tv and she's like i don't know how to do
that why don't you try to make it and
then i got in the kitchen started
cooking and i fell in love initially
with like the whole like i cook the
thing then i get to eat it i was very
like goal driven and then eventually
just i fell in love with like the
creative aspect and you know just being
able to use that as an outlet to express
my creativity and eventually like the
art of cooking
hey it's a todd welcome back to my
channel today it is time for the
ultimate pizza show down
eitan bernat is an entertainer
entrepreneur and chef with a massive
online following
only 19 years old bernath's content
reaches more than 300 million consumers
globally running a cooking blog as a
teenager and appearing on more food
shows helped bernath break into the food
industry i was probably on social media
before technically i was allowed to by
the terms of service not gonna lie but i
think for me i started on instagram i
started with my food blog tick tock i
started in october of 2019 i actually
made a bet with one of my teachers that
i can get a video to hit a million views
by the end of the school year and it was
basically like if i win the bet this
class has to buy me dinner and if i lose
the bet i'll cook the whole class dinner
later that day i made a video that got a
million views in four hours and i posted
this video it was like
a video of my school's cafeteria and it
went viral and then i just kept posting
and posting and i think i just fell in
love with performing you know i think
now if someone asks me like what i love
doing what my passion is i would
definitely say entertaining people
obviously cooking's my passion but i
think i've learned that i really love
entertaining people getting people
excited about food you know i'm not
going to ramsey i'm not trying to be
gordon ramsay i'm not a restaurant
trained chef i'm atom i like to learn
about food i like to take my followers
along that journey and i think that kind
of approachability and relatability has
led to a lot of my success because like
i think i'm good at cooking but i'm not
an expert and i think because of that
i'm able to really show people that they
can do it too and i think for me like
that was really a pivotal moment with
tick tock where once i started growing
in there i was like oh okay i love
cooking but you know what i really love
i love entertaining i love educating i
mean both my parents are teachers so
it definitely runs in my blood
bernath cut his teeth in social media by
not only working on his own brand but
also by working with brands to produce
content for their platforms while in
high school through his production
company eitan productions
at one point bernath says he was running
12 social media accounts for different
brands but as his own profile began to
rise in late 2020 he shifted his
company's focus exclusively to his own
brand
then in january of 2021 i moved into
manhattan and hired my first full-time
employee rachel my executive culinary
producer because very quickly the
culinary needs of the business were
expanding rapidly and i was releasing
more content developing more recipes and
it was more than i myself could handle
very quickly it went from like just me
little aton in my parents kitchen
filming videos to eton in manhattan with
my team of six full-time employees
creating
a massive amount of content this is what
i always had dreamed of um you know
owning my own media company creating
lots of content i then landed my role on
the drew barrymore show so i was now
doing reoccurring television and it was
really just like a dream come true and
it like it still is
all that success has helped fornath land
a cookbook deal bernath says he wants
his cookbook to take his followers along
with him on his culinary journey
bringing to life recipes he's developed
over the years my goal with the cookbook
is the same goal as i have with kind of
all my content but in a very like
tangible physical way which is what
excites me is my goal is to get people
excited to cook in the kitchen i want
them to have fun in the kitchen i want
them to cook and enjoy doing it i try to
do a diverse set of recipes in the book
there's things like my pb j pancakes
super easy anyone could do them kids can
do them with their parents super
approachable the flavor palette in there
is like very
everyone will like it but then there's
recipes where i want to like push people
out of their comfort zone a little bit
you know get people to try things and
flavor combinations techniques and maybe
only order at restaurants but like try
it at home you'll you'll enjoy it
[Music]
you